Hello, I'm Negar Mortazavi with VOA 60 elections.
For days, the media have been hurling tough questions at Republican presidential candidate Mitt Romney.
Yesterday, President Obama came in for some tough questioning.
At a town hall meeting hosted by the Spanish language network Univision,...
...CBS News says Obama was repeatedly asked why he broke promise of introducing comprehensive immigration reform...
...during his first year in office.
"A promise is a promise," said a Univision interviewer, "and with all due respect, but you didn't keep that promise."
The president responded by blaming his Republican opposition in congress.
Meanwhile, Fox News reports Obama had about 89 million dollars at the end of August to spend on his campaign.
That's nearly twice as much as Romney had.
And a new poll finds Obama leads Romney in battleground states of Colorado, Iowa and Wisconsin.
In Colorado and Wisconsin, NBC News says Obama is ahead by five points and in Iowa, eight points.
That's all for today.
See you next time.